hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the age-old
question of how on Earth Harry's parents
amassed such an incredible amount of
wealth how is it that Harry's Vault was
absolutely bursting at the seams from
galleons when the Vault of an entire
family the Weasleys had but just one
single Galleon we're also going to be
looking at why Rowling made the decision
to make Harry as wealthy as he was when
the Philosopher's Stone was first
released we got our first look into the
contents of Harry's Vault Vault 687 when
Hagrid escorts him to gring Gods
griphook unlocked the door a lot of
Green Smoke came blowing out and as it
cleared Harry gasped inside were mounds
of gold coins Columns of silver heaps of
little bronze canards all yours smiled
Hagrid and from the first time I read
that passage I became fascinated with
Harry's immense Fortune how did he get
it how much was there and what did these
immense stacks of gold coins look like
fortunately this scene was brought to
life on screen in the release of the
Philosopher's Stone in 2001 and it
allowed us to finally witness with our
own eyes exactly what Harry would have
seen when he first up foot in Vault 687
I'd also like to point out that this
scene was preceded by Harry asking but
Hagrid how am I to pay for all this I
haven't any money oh Harry so again I
ask where on Earth did Harry's parents
who were just 21 years old when they
died get all this gold to leave for
Harry there are two components to this
answer the first involves the Canon
explanation for the gold with in-depth
information on where it came from and
the second involves a theory of mine
that may account for why these existing
stacks of gold were made even larger
after the deaths of Harry's parents let
me first dive into the former the first
thing needs to be established is that
the vast wealth came almost entirely
from James's side of the family Lily
Evans was a muggleborn and there's no
evidence to support that her family had
any kind of generational wealth bearing
that in mind who was at the started the
pot of Fortune well according to an
article on Pottermore it all started
with the wizard by the name of Linford
of stinchcombe aka the potterer the
founding patriarch of the Potter family
The Wizarding family of Potters descends
from the 12th century wizard Linford of
stinchcombe a locally well-beloved and
eccentric man whose nickname the possura
became corrupted in time to Potter
Linford was a vague and answered minded
fellow whose muggle neighbors often
called upon his medicinal Services none
of them realized that linford's
wonderful cures for pox and egg were
magical they all thought him a harmless
and lovable old chap pottering about in
his garden with all his funny plants his
reputation as a well-meaning eccentric
served Linford well for behind closed
doors he was able to continue the series
of experiments that laid the foundation
of the Potter family's Fortune
historians credit Linford as the
originator of a number of remedies that
evolved into potions still used to this
day including skeligro and pepfra potion
his sales of such cures to fellow
witches and wizards enabled him to leave
a significant pile of gold to each of
his seven children upon his death if you
recognize Scala grow well that's because
it's still used to this day notably on
Harry in the Chamber of Secrets the
function of skellagrow is to heal bones
capable of both repairing broken bones
and growing backbones that are missing
entirely it is described as a dreadful
tasting potion and Harry once remarked
that using it felt like having large
splinters lodged in his arm the other
potion created by Linford the pepper
potion is a cure for the common cold
helping to warm the Drinker up the
potion was notably used in the series in
February 1995 during the triumphed
tournament when it was used on the
hostages of the Champions after they
came out of the Great Lake the only
known side effect is that it causes
steam to come out of the drinker's ears
for hours on end but Linford wasn't the
only one in the family to become
successful he just kicked things off The
Potters continued to marry their
neighbors occasionally Muggles and to
live in the west of England for several
Generations each one adding to the
family coffers by their hard work and it
must be said by the quiet brand of
Ingenuity that it characterized their
forebear Linford occasionally a Potter
made it all the way to London and the
member of the family has twice sat on
the wizard gamuts Ralston Potter who was
a member from 1612 to 1652 and who was a
great supporter of the statute of
secrecy as opposed to declaring war on
the Muggles as more militant members
wish to do and Henry Potter Harry to his
Intimates and while many of The Potters
were able to achieve success in their
respective careers slowly growing the
family fortune it wasn't until Fremont
Potter came about that fuel really
started to get added to the fire flamont
was the son of Henry and father two you
guessed it James Potter this of course
also means that Fremont was Harry's
grandfather
Fremont may have never met Harry but he
did live long enough to make and leave
him enough gold for a lifetime you see
Fremont was able to take the family
fortune and quadruple it by creating the
family's most famous potion to date
sleeky's hair potion the potion was a
hair potion and scalp treatment marketed
with the following slogan two drops came
even the most bothersome Barn is it was
essentially used for taming unruly hair
sleekly and fashionably styling it the
potion was notably used by Hermione when
she went to the Yule Ball with Victor
crum in short the immense wealth of The
Potters can be attributed to centuries
of sales from multiple successful and
extremely prevalent potions given the
long-standing generational wealth of The
Potters it's certainly not surprising
that Harry was left with an absolute
boatload of cash but with that
explanation on the table I have a theory
for how these mounds of gold may have
grown even further after the deaths of
Harry's parents
when Voldemort died and how he survived
he was praised by the entire Wizarding
World for somehow taking out the dark
lord and relieving The Wizarding
community of his tyranny it was also
common knowledge that Harry's parents
had died in the process I'm of the
impression that thousands of witches and
wizards feeling empathy for the young
boy who had lost his parents banded
together and donated additional gold to
him the exact Fortune of The Potters
would have been unclear to The Wizarding
World as a whole so from the outside
perspective it may have looked as if
this newborn child was now left with
nothing no parents and no gold it stands
to reason that the general Wizarding
population
Overjoyed with Voldemort's defeat would
have tried to thank Harry in some way
maybe they couldn't bring back his
parents but with enough contributors
they could certainly make sure that he
was financially worry-free we also have
to consider royalties if Harry's
ancestors created famous and popular
potions that was still sold during his
lifetime then it stands to reason that
he would be entitled to proceeds from
the sales of said potions furthermore
given the prevalence of these potions
I'd be willing to bet that it'd add up
quite quickly with the question of how
Harry obtained gold out of the way the
next thing I want to address is why why
on Earth did Rowling decide to make
Harry's wealth a prominent plot Point
why did she make him rich as it turns
out she's actually answered this very
question in an interview where does
Harry get his money he always seems to
have some does he have a bank account
where is it where's his money well as
you know Harry's bank account is in
gring Gods his money came from
inheritance from his father but I think
on a deeper level Harry's money never
really is that important in the books
except that he can afford his uniform
and so on on the other hand I think I
really gave him a fortune because I was
so broke when I wrote the first book and
it was wishful thinking that I would not
have to worry about such things
rolling rotary is Rich because in the
world that she lived in she had nothing
this was in the beginning of the very
first Harry Potter book which of course
means that while writing this passage
Rowling had no publisher no money and
probably not a lot of Hope
writing Harry is a rich young boy was
her way of projecting her future desires
looking at Harry as an extension of
herself
and that's it for this video I hope that
clarifies some questions regarding the
Potter family wealth if you have any
more questions on this topic or have any
requests for derivatives of this topic
then please leave a comment down below
until next time remember wit beyond
measure is man's greatest treasure
foreign